from the guy who directed Honey I Shrunk
the Kids comes okay so Benicio del Toro
plays Lawrence Talbot a supposed
accomplished actor who returns to his
homeland of Great Britain after his
brothers savagely mauled by a beast and
yeah that's mauled it's in the dead
moles not mauled as in Loomis's that's
right is your mind blown yet Benicio del
Toro takes on his most challenging role
of all he plays a guy who was supposedly
a good actor must have taken all the
strength he could muster the young dish
actor then gets bitten by this beast and
then 30 minutes of choppy and horribly
paced character development later he
finally Wolf's out 45 minutes into the
movie now granted the Wolfman is kind of
hard to do because he'll only wolf out
on everyone once a month the other 29
days you're just stuck with the
characters and no wolf which would be
fine if the in-between time was filled
with good characters that you remotely
care about or had workable pacing in
between werewolf phases each month but
it doesn't and it doesn't and if it
fails on those come on it's gotta at
least have cool werewolf scenes of
Awesomeness because I mean who are we
kidding that's why I wanted to watch it
that no I mean seriously it fails on all
those so but the werewolf scenes are
about five minutes long max and if he's
not running on all fours a horrible CGI
style he runs like this and then a few
people get clawed decapitated and
eviscerated and then it's over onto more
horrible pacing until the next werewolf
session keep in mind that in between
full moons they cram a month into about
15 minutes of screen time and they do it
about four times over in the movie yeah
it's rough and kind of shitty as for the
actors again
Benicio his best role Franky four
fingers from snatch his worst all the
others I mean Greta the guy won an Oscar
in traffic by speaking Spanish a
language that I'm willing to bet nobody
on the Academy even speaks he might as
well have been speaking Klingon to them
to them yeah once again he is less than
great I mean honestly it's just his
acting style he's so blah and you can't
be so blah if you're supposed to get me
to care that you're an average nice guy
who's now dealing with a moral dilemma
because you wolfed out and shredded a
bunch of villagers I mean come on
Benicio del Toro Taylor Lautner what is
it with werewolves being depicted by
shitty actors except for Michael Sheen
in underworld he was harsh Hugo Weaving
in this movie I liked him I mean no one
movie really stands out but Hugo Weaving
he's accomplished he's diverse he's good
I liked him Anthony Hopkins straight-up
steals all his scenes from his co-star
Benicio del Toro but so did other moving
and iconic characters in this movie like
creepy gypsy lady number four little kid
running through the fog and dead guy
laying on a slab in the butcher shop and
emily Blunt's in it Emily Blunt to be
blunt I actually didn't hate her in the
movie she serves one purpose and she
does it very well and that is to give us
something to look at to help us through
the horrible pacing in between werewolf
scenes as for the werewolf
transformation scenes when he's turning
I mean they were cool and all but I mean
we've seen werewolf transformations a
hundred times over by now is this not
new anymore I did however like some
things about it like when his fangs are
coming in you see his teeth like
cracking and falling out that was cool
how he gets his regular teeth back the
next morning I don't know honestly it's
probably the least of there's movies
problems ultimately I mean the movies
not as bad as van Helsing but it's not
like up there with Bram Stoker's Dracula
just imagine if a lesser form of Sleepy
Hollow like [ __ ] the pacing from
angley's Hulk and had a kid but the best
I can compare that would pretty much be
the Wolfman so if you like good pacing
interesting characters or even some
really cool werewolfism that you'd
expect from a sweet-ass werewolf movie
you might want to sit this one out who
knows it might be worth letting your
girlfriend drag you to the movie
Valentine's Day this weekend but if you
liked this review or found it at least
mildly tolerable then click on the link
in the sidebar to see more and maybe
even subscribe who knows you might just
like it or just click here
Oh